son 900 los cuerpos que han sido
descubiertos por el momento como bien
nos dijo el comandante de la policía
regional que se encuentran regularmente
cuerpos que siguen dentro de los
escombros o que estaban en un refugio en
el subsuelo de sus viviendas y sobre los
que esas construcciones que se
desplomaron todavía quedan por descubrir
aunque piensan que la mayoría ya fue
descubierta el funcionario afirmó que se
trataba de 900 civiles
900 cuerpos que primero fueron recogidos
en las calles con mucho cuidado
esto tomó mucho tiempo porque algunos
estaban atrapados y fueron llevados a un
instituto médico legal para que se le
realizara una autopsia y determinar las
causas de su fallecimiento
aún así nos explicaban que era evidente
que la gran mayoría fueron asesinados
por balas
después de estos cuerpos fueron
identificados los que han sido
identificados son llevados a las
familias para ser enterrados y los otros
son conservados hasta que puedan ser
identificados es un trabajo minucioso el
que hacen los investigadores
localidad al norte de kiev también se
trata de recoger muchos testimonios un
máximo posible de testimonios sobre
casos de torturas sobre casos de
violaciones
ciertamente es muy complicado para los
investigadores porque múltiples víctimas
no quieren revivir lo que vivieron no
quieren asumir la magnitud y la lentitud
de este proceso no quieren revivir
a veces no quieren que sus familias
sepan lo que pasó sobre todo en los
casos de violación
los policías se apoyan también sobre
ongs para recoger un máximo posible de
testimonios y escribir un informe que
será transmitido a las autoridades
internacionales competentes como la
corte penal internacional que será la
habilitada para determinar si fueron
crímenes de lesa humanidad crímenes de
guerra o como se lo escuchamos decir a
ciertos políticos de genocidio